benefit 2.0 takes spain
we're just
having a good time jennifer lopez and
ben affleck were seen gazing into each
other's eyes
and walking hand in hand in the country
known for its passion
jayla was filming her latest film the
mother the thriller that she is both
starring and serving as producer in is
about an assassin who comes out of
hiding to protect her daughter she gave
up early in life you're not promised
tomorrow and you have to you have to
love and live for today speaking of that
while ben is in spain supporting
jennifer on set he recently took his
support a step further by joining the
shoot for her latest music video the
ballot version of jen's track marry me
that coincides with the movie soundtrack
baby you're my shelter
shelter from a broken paradise
i couldn't dream it any better if i
tried
this comes nearly two decades after ben
starred in jennifer's jenny from the
block music video
[Music]
however
unlike the clear visuals we got of ben
during that shoot his appearance this
time around is much more subtle i have
no explanation for that in fact in this
music video we never see the oscar
winners face instead we get intimate
glimpses of the couple's time in bed
goofing around cuddling and holding each
other's hand it just turned out to be
something really magical last month a
source told et that the formerly engaged
pair is quote open to the possibility of
getting engaged again and married i've
heard you say so many times that you are
a hopeless romantic and you still
believe in love you believe in marriage
so like cat you still believe in all of
those absolutely why wouldn't i
we're super happy
um
what can i tell you we're just having a
good time i would be remiss if i didn't
say you were standing taking photos in
front of a sign that says marry me
it's very big i didn't really realize
how big
[Laughter]
our source says quote ben and jen are so
in love their loved ones would not be
surprised if ben pops the question of
course they will be considerate of their
children when thinking about moving
forward with their relationship adding
quote they both want things to be great
between their kids not just the two of
them
[Music]